I don't know the facts yet and I've
learned from being in this business I
read an article about me today that was
not true not that it wasn't true but
that facts were not presented in a way
that gave a full color of what really
was going on so I'm under I'm having
being in the center and reading about
yourself I'm so slow to make judgments
until the truth comes out so I withhold
judgment on on speech but if a
politician or not even politician other
careers somebody that has the public
trust it's guilty of a federal crime
yeah they should resign so i will say
that but uh but we as a people let's
look less as he resigns as he loses
dignity loses face oh and so forth i
hope that we all as conduct ourselves in
a way of compassion I guess what I think
this we mated let's not make too much of
the deal so that you know there are
people in every industry in every sector
that have foibles and faults and commit
crimes so I don't want to talk about it
there's no trend there's no you know it
just so happens that we've had three
governors resigned under under painful
and embarrassing so forth conditions but
come on the reality is you know I
remember I gave I went out to it was a
Colorado that I was embarrassed i'm
forgetting exactly where i was giving
this talk but it was too it was a group
of local leaders from all across america
and i was supposed to give a was a
counselor at the time but i was giving a
speech on ethics in politics and i sat
there and listening to the breakout
groups and seeing the city council
people state assembly all these local
people hundreds and hundreds of them
most Americans in the public sector or
first of all making huge sacrifices
they're not like me or other people that
are in the paper every day or get there
just doing it because they love their
town they love their city they live
there
unity and they're serving so let's not
paint a broad brush on politicians there
the overwhelming majority of Americans
are good people that just want to see
their communities make a difference and
there are there are a whole bunch of
governors and you know Toby right now we
got 50 actually well maybe 49 but then
another guy will get sworn in that are
just amazing people and will every human
being as a mountain range we all have
peaks and we all have valleys and Lord
knows we all have dark corners and the
challenge for politics is that you are
in such the public spectacle that your
stuff eventually going to come out if
it's there and especially in these days
this day and age so we may be catching
people with more rapidity but that's
maybe because that the technology and
the surveillance and all that stuff is
getting much better that what is it
really is revealing as the reality of
our of humanity and as big as soon as we
start thinking our politicians are not
human we're fooling ourselves and and
probably and perhaps there for
portraying the possibilities if we if we
had more realistic understanding of
human nature no no I disagree with that
and I think that um ultimately I believe
and I fix in my life the intense
challenge is that my team is faced and
there are people in my team that I've
made more sacrifices than I have for
this bring out and often select for the
best of human character and and the best
of who we are so I'm not critical of the
process I mean they're they're
definitely times i wish i had more
privacy and this came and but as a
trade-off and there's a whole lot of
pressure but i didn't i wasn't forced
into this office I I sort of chose it
and made a lot of sacrifices to get it
so I don't think it's too much to expect
that the voters who vote for me and put
their faith in me and believe in me
should should expect that I conduct
myself with a you know a high moral
character and a fiercely rigid moral
compass and I have to make choices
differently you know
um there are definitely ways in which
I've become personally more conservative
where I won't put myself even in
situations anymore that could undermine
the public good in which i'm trying to
do or even give the appearance of
impropriety and we should expect those
things from political years i don't
think it's a thing something that we
shouldn't I'm just saying that when a
person falls when a person stumbles even
or a person falls on their sword that we
shouldn't dance on their graves and we
shouldn't make grandiose things like all
these politicians are evil or or this
person was a really really bad person
look Spencer did a horrible thing but
said the totality of the man should not
be about this one instant of his life
did he do some good things where the
people see in the state of New York did
he help some people along the way so
let's not write his epitaph as he was
somebody that used a prostitute and was
a hypocrite in that effort and by the
way all the facts haven't come out yet
so you never you never know I just I
just I just the two-part answer which
should I should have said in too much
shorter way is one is if you accept a
position of leadership yes you should
comport yourself and conduct yourself in
a certain way and you should recognize
and I say this for athletes to people
say well why should it have to be a role
model like come on you know you got kids
wearing New Jersey all over the country
yeah you're a role model and behave like
one and don't behave like a child but at
the same time I'm a big believer in
compassion and love if somebody falls
you gotta you gotta treat him that way
and you know when I hear people cheering
that he's you know and all this kind of
stuff I you know it's just I just think
it's a little over the top
Oh